foreign
[Music]
owners of this store in England LED an
attempted robber go free
Dylan's video caught what looked like a
customer browsing through the phone
market a cell phone store in West
Yorkshire UK
after getting two phones in his hand to
compare the hooded man makes a run for
the door only to find out that it's
locked from the inside
give me the phone stupid
I love the energy [__] didn't
even budge they knew what the [__] they
was doing
I love that [__] nobody moved across the
button because the button been pressed
they saw this why do
listen listen we've seen enough we've
seen enough of EastEnders we've seen
enough of UK television or no we don't
trust no gingers give me back the phones
I love it they didn't even put look at
this [__] it's precious shout out it's
beautiful
Linda walkashame The Walker same is
great play that [__] you have to walk by
Yo Ahmed man hear your phones no it was
this it was this this is what I love
oh
I'm sorry
and you know this you know this in the
UK because in America they would have
pulled guns look look at this [__]
the would-be thief brings the phones
back to the counter and makes his
excuses
the two men behind the counter remain
calm
[Music]
but they didn't the shop owner absal
Adam not only let the suspect go he
posted the video to Twitter asking the
almost robber to come back he wrote the
times are difficult for many of us at
the moment so if you are struggling to
put food on the table please come visit
us in the store to see how we can help
Adam credits his Muslim faith with
teaching him to be merciful and
forgiving shout outs to you that's a
double win that shout outs to you save
the phones made the business look Fire
Man allegedly fatally stabbed a man who
confronted him for Bad Manners
the victim held open a door for the man
who did not say thank you police say
the man was arrested and charged with
manslaughter and criminal possession of
a weapon
what a dumb reason to die so basically
he was charged with manslaughter
what happened why it was the guy in the
white was holding the door the guy goes
through but he doesn't say thank you so
that goes in he's like hey bro you're
not gonna say thank you
chopped cheese whatever they say New
York
okay
yeah whatever man and the Mason excuse
me
he said excuse me he said you're not
gonna say thank you chopped cheese
whatever man
I don't even pretend like I know New
York like that
you're not gonna say thank you chopped
cheese
so so the best excuse me and he said
you're not gonna say this so I have an
alteration and the guy who said you're
not gonna say thank you get stabbed and
dust that's crazy
yeah
people are not well
people are not well who's not well in
this situation the man who loses it
because somebody didn't say thank you or
the guy who stabbed him because he got
aggressive you saw his posture he looked
like he was trying to fight him guys
I don't know who's the Dumber one in
this whole situation it's hard to tell
well the thing that happened is that
when you fight a pig in the mud
from the distance at some point you
can't tell who's who
and at the end of the day you you
realize that the pig likes it
so when you fight like that you don't
know who's who that's that's what
happens
you don't know who's who Hey listen
who's dumb and who's not could it be me
I open doors for many people I've never
said where's my thank you [__]
you know what's crazy is that a lot of
these murders and deaths can just be so
easily avoided if [__] just
walk away
Let It Go
just let it go it's not even important
that is just dumb behavior and that's
what people do kind of like that white
man in the parking lot that we covered
before the old man could have died
easily the old man could have died he
did a reverse and went back part that's
that dumb [__] twice that's that dumb
[__] that's that dumb [__] like yo let
it go it's not even important and by the
time you're dealing with a serious
relation way more serious you're gonna
wish you let it go sure your pride might
be a little bit annoyed who cares it's
too late now you guys are out here dying
because some [__] didn't say
thank you like what is y'all doing
knowing there's that much instability
here's the thing
I don't act like that when I'm in Canada
or in Europe
y'all doing that in America but they're
Americans
so last I checked Americans are not
immune from stab wounds that's not what
is that something on the RPG chart
character chart yes are they immune from
gun bullets no but they don't like they
they they it's normal
walking around like that is normal to
them so I guess I guess they just
Americans are constantly aware of the
security dangerous and the threats
they're not immune to it if you know
your place is [__] dangerous you
don't act like that I'm not saying
they're immune to it there's just a
certain
I'm home nothing's gonna happen to me
you know whenever you think they think
that
you think they think when they're in
their City nothing's gonna happen some
of them some of them might think that
because they did in the hood they're in
their Hood you know when when you drive
around in your car
they say that most accidents happen near
your house because you're you're your
your vigilance is actually lower because
you're close to home you know these
stuff you know this your normal routine
so your villager lens is really lower
right and
but maybe that's what I'm not saying
that 100 they don't think they're gonna
die but because they know the corner
store they go that's their spot the way
I see Americans and people from New York
ripping their hood and [__] that's my
hood [__] you're not gonna say thank
you Maji you think he's not I don't know
I maybe I'm I'm probably wrong but maybe
there's a sense of there's a sense of
like
being home and it's not I wouldn't call
it safety because some of the hoods are
hoods but at the end of the day you
don't think this shit's gonna happen
this lead to you
I mean I don't even believe that's true
because they see people around them
dying all the time yep and that's like
and that's all people talk about how
they feel unsafe in America every poll
shows that they feel unsafe in their own
country they feel like crime is crazy
through the roof right now so why would
you ever think about beefing over
somebody those people that are that are
that are unsafe or not the ones that are
gonna fight for it thank you if you
fight for it thank you or you will go up
to someone like that for a thank you you
think you must have something that they
don't have
but maybe not I'm probably wrong I just
think they're unstable I think you have
to be a certain level of unstable to
want to fight somebody over someone not
saying thank you
that's the truth I think there's
something a little bit sick in the
prideful culture of a lot of men where
they feel like they gotta puff out their
chests all the time over dumb [__] I
think they're aware of the nature I
think they just don't care
I think a lot of them don't care
or they're so clouded by their emotions
that they gonna just have a moment where
even though they're aware if you were to
ask them on any other day of the week
like are you aware of how danger starts
in your neighborhood they're like yeah
they're well aware
but you get a little bit mouthy with
somebody and all of a sudden you start
thinking rationally
you could even see a cop on the corner
and you're still gonna fight the person
in front of you because you're so mad
about situations how many times have I
seen cops just standing right there and
dudes who know and see the cops are
starting punching each other out right
in front of the police officers why
because they mad and they're upset
emotions I think that's what it really
comes down to that's why they gave it
manslaughter and it wasn't premeditated
because this [__] was a spur of the
moment thing where you not think
irrational but it's just one of those
things where
if I know I'm in a dangerous place
I'm already thinking de-escalation every
time I'm not thinking about my pride
because I'm not rocking a bunch of
weapons on me on all times of the day so
why would I even think that and even if
I was the last thing I want to do is see
who's got better accuracy
just cause I got it on me doesn't mean I
want to have to use it you know what I'm
saying but man this is just my brain the
way it works I can't understand that
like I can understand it I just don't
understand how you get in your 30s and
you still like that you hear me a young
I understand young people are done
before
you in your 30s and you still can't
regulate your emotions at all to be
smart and look
it's just one of those things where I'm
like
some of y'all grown but you're not
really grown see what I'm going to say
that's at least the way I see it because
my friends when I'm in the stage like
they're constantly aware like
how everything is but the ones who stood
up getting in situations at least from
my perspective is uh
a few screws missing over here and there
but anyways
what you guys think in the comments
below between the two videos we saw one
wholesome one the one deadly one you
know good balance in life
what
no
one knows yeah
you know
yeah you don't see the difference though
the First videos in the UK there's an
attempted robbery nothing happens yeah
well no violence and then you go to bed
America say thank you
I'm not I'm not and then you get too
long I'm not gonna be like do you King
got that violence because they got
stabbings and they got matchstabings and
Matt acid throw acid thrown in their
face so I'm not gonna be like oh you
know what the people from there I'm not
gonna do that I'll say this people
mention that stuff and it is partially
true but per capita is not even close to
comparable to America Fair like
I don't think people realize how crazy
crime in America is yeah like asset
attacks we talk about them because
they're so bizarre to us but really it's
just because they got a lot of brown
people and that's just popular from like
those places but really asset attacks
are not as common as you think
surprisingly and especially when you
compare to more deadly forms of crime
that happen in America they're not even
close the one city in America could
probably overtake all of the UK for
murders
a year here let me look it up sure
murder England
per year
go find that the US is just wild
I looked at the numbers and the numbers
is crazy
multiply
eight times more homicides
in the states yeah per per million okay
so for many people per million
that's crazy that means there's even
more assaults
so it just shows you like America is
really its Unleashed
a lot of everything is like gang drug
related but still not necessarily what
you mean that was not drug related that
was not game related it was thank you
related this one I'm talking about just
in general though and the other one was
parking related
in general most of like the number one
it's so inflatedly high the other one
was phone related yeah yeah it was most
of the numbers are actually just gang
members just killing each other or
drug-related crimes yeah yeah I mean
even here
other side it's pretty
drug or gangster
games four or five that we sure
people see the numbers and they freak
out but they don't realize generally
just gang members smirking each other
yeah or people fighting over drug
territory yeah but anyways we don't want
to get too deep into it let us know what
you guys think in the comments below
this can be a patreon exclusive all
right that's covering a couple different
videos in a single one let us know if
you guys like this format you want to
hear from me hello related